[Musique]
l'amour passe avant le football ça c'est
un conseil que je donne jamais faire
passer le football avant l'amour donc
pas de match tant pis bam padre alpap
psg à une inconnue chiante à mourir si
j'étais célibataire ça me dérange pas me
le fait qu'elle soit inconnu ni le fait
qu'elle soit chiante
parce qu elle est chiante parce qu'on
est chiant avec elle avec moi serait
jamais chiante la femme de ma vie le
jour de la saint-valentin gelé déjà
rencontré mais sinon saint valentin
j'adore la saint valentin chez un fan
c'est la mère de mon meilleur ami
ça me dérangerait pas donc c'est pas sa
femme la mère de mon meilleur ami très
bien très bien pas de problème quoi sur
de poignard est d'ailleurs gelé
aujourd'hui ça me va très bien
donc là d'être concluants problème c'est
que je chante faux donc ça va faire le
mec qui tentent de chanter de chanter
faux alors que les sardines je serai
ridicule d'emblée je pense que femme qui
trouve un nombre ridicule femme à moitié
et c'est donc les sardines à moi j'ai
pris le resto quoi qu'il arrive donc
rendu seul accompagné je paye le resto
c'est impossible qu'une femme soit avec
moi à dîner sans que je paye je peux
passer de l'éducation je peux pas je
peux pas